so now this is a this is really
calling this a fireside
so let me let me introduce mark and then
ask him to introduce his colleagues so
so mark is entrepreneur in residence
here at Yale he's accomplished a lot in
you know his uh his in his youth he's
been a successful investor he's a lawyer
and an MBA he set up a royalty fund went
into I don't know quasi retirement and
then and came here to to benefit us as
entrepreneur in residence and he's
continuing his entrepreneurial
activities of working to leverage the
the developments and intellectual
property from from our university as
well as others to to continue to build
innovation so thank you very much and
give it to you perfect let me just
introduce my two colleagues just to
start
David is a scientist and entrepreneur
he's worked in the DNA sequencing space
for many years and most recently he's
undertaken over the past few years a
very big project in the digital pharmacy
space so I'm excited to talk to him
about that today and John has a long
history and background as an analyst and
consultant in the across the health care
spectrum and he's now the vice president
of client services at Tru various life
sciences and I'm gonna ask him to talk
about that part of the business as well
as treviris more broadly in our in our
discussion before we dive into our
discussion let me just give a little bit
of background for everyone in the room
because you may not be that familiar
with the drug supply chain space and
drug supply chain is essentially this
very very complex web of pairs pharmacy
benefit managers distributors and
pharmacies basically all everyone around
that who stands between the
manufacturers of drugs and the end
patient and and serves the barrier but
also as a buffer in that process and
that landscape in the past few years has
been changing very very rapidly a few
different causes for that the first is a
lot of big mergers and acquisitions the
most famous of being the Aetna CVS
merger the Express Scripts Cigna merger
that just happened this past year second
is if you haven't checked in lately the
government has been very focused on drug
pricing and on PPM's and on all of the
activity going on in that space and
realized there's a lot of folks making a
lot of money doing things that nobody
really understands and hopefully we'll
get a little light on that in today's
discussion but where's the hope first
off there's a lot of new entrants
there's a lot of smaller innovative tech
players entering there's also some
giants entering Harlan had mentioned
Amazon kind of as a little bit of a joke
early on in today's discussion but I
would say we're gonna talk about Amazon
very seriously because they're a big
digital transformer in the drug supply
chain space and their acquisition of
pillpack is just one of many things that
they're doing and finally it's really
that the the fact that this space is
experiencing a wave of digitization and
innovation that we haven't seen like of
really since this whole industry came
into being and it makes it a very
exciting time to be in it it also means
it's it's very hard to keep up and
that's why it's good to have experts in
the room to to elucidate some of that
for us so maybe the best place to start
is to turn the discussion over to to
David to talk to us a bit about Valles
or help us understand what an analytical
pharmacy is and how digitization plays
into the the company strategy sure thank
you very much thanks for having me do
you want to control the slides to take
some branding opportunities so
vali sure is essentially an online
pharmacy that's obviously a big
up-and-coming area Amazon buying fill
packs certainly has infused a lot of
attention into this space but where as
all of our competitors in the online
pharmacy space are really focused on
convenience and
niches of various drugs for specific
populations what valo sure focuses on is
the quality of the medication itself
which is a universal value add of course
and so we're an online pharmacy that's
attached an analytical laboratory and
what that means is we're actually
chemically analyzing the the actual
chemical quality of every single batch
of every single medication screening
those that don't pass our rigorous
analysis and then we dispense
medications that pass direct to
consumers that come not just with our
brand value but with a certificate of
analysis very much like nutritional
information I mean you wouldn't buy food
without nutritional information but yet
all you know about your meds is it comes
in an orange bottle and these days over
eighty percent of the of the drug
materials are manufactured in India and
China ninety percent of the drugs that
people take our generic a lot of talk
about drug prices and and you know new
drugs that are extremely expensive but
the reality is the vast majority of the
drugs that most people take day-to-day
are generic very cheap and and those
prices hit rock-bottom years ago and
really we should be a lot more concerned
about the quality actually speaking at
Yale is nice the way that balusters came
about was a good friend of mine from
Yale that called me up was telling me
about all the problems he was having
with his anticonvulsant medications I
think we're talking about antiepileptic
clinical trial before and it was a
previous speaker I mean it's definitely
an area that people can be very affected
by medication variability anything that
affects the brain mental health heart
health people been feeling these issues
especially when there's so many
different generic manufacturers they all
make them differently they're legally
allowed to vary 45% from one another and
it's bioavailability which is what
actually affects you so our solution was
essentially doing all this analysis up
front doing it in large batches with our
own proprietary technologies we
developed our own laser based analytical
system to do this kind of analysis much
faster much easier much more
interchangeable so we can do many
different drugs at the same time but
still very high precision
so we have an iso accredited facility
actually the FDA doesn't oversee
analytics if it's not part of the
manufacturing facility so we're kind of
outside of that but we went to the
international standards organization to
make sure we get a strong accreditation
on the reproducibility and consistency
of our technology and long story short a
lot of information behind that but what
really gets to the consumer is the fact
that they have a chemically validated
medication and what we've we've started
to see a lot from the healthcare
industry so we launched only a few
months ago end of 2018 and we've seen a
lot of engagement now also from
healthcare systems so pharmacy benefit
managers that aren't the big evil ones
like you know some of the big ones
you've heard of but you know smaller
ones like Capital rx said hey we're a
transparent pharmacy benefit manager we
actually are trying to add value into
the system lower prices but also have
higher quality wherever we can find it
so you know capital rect specifically
also does pharmacogenomic testing so you
can get the most efficient medication
for you and then having a pharmacy that
can ship your medications is chemically
validated just made total sense to them
and so we just announced a partnership
about a month ago we're starting to get
a lot of engagement from hospitals that
want to see validated medications in
their own systems especially with some
of the famous recalls like valsartan
losartan you know which was affected by
cancer causing contaminants from dirty
manufacturing in China so the concept of
having a validated generic has never
really happened before and can really
help out patients doctors and the
healthcare system and I think quite a
intro there sorry for taking some time
yeah yeah well I want to build on
something you were describing you
talking talk about the PBMs is a
potentially not the most loved
institutions in the u.s. right now and
John maybe you can help unpack that a
little bit for us and tell us overall
what's rivera´s has been doing to try to
solve some of those problems yeah so
with all transparency we didn't know
this until we walked up here but his
partner and capital R X is actually
founded by the co-founder of eros and my
former
so small world small worlds that exists
but yeah so so treviris was actually
founded and the premise was trying to
build transparency into a market that is
basically built around the big black box
that's been created over the past 20 or
so years by a lot of these sort of
institutional entities that exist PBMs
as well as others so our vision and sort
of mission is to basically help people
live healthier lives by making their
prescription drugs more affordable we're
not a not-for-profit though we do it you
know in a sort of a start-up in business
manner but we have two areas of business
one focusing on what we call employer
payer services that focus on TBMs and
their relationships with employers and
on life sciences so to Mark's point we
started in that PBM space because our
co-founders were working in a different
industry and we're talking with a large
self-insured employer who were saying
that every Tuesday or every other
Tuesday they got a bill for 12 million
dollars from their PBM that said hey pay
me in 48 hours here's one line item it
says it's 12 million dollars you gotta
pay me by you know by Thursday and yes
we'll let you check into some of the
things at the end of the year maybe and
they looked at that and said imagine
getting a bill from Amex that said one
pay me tomorrow I'm not gonna tell you
what you're paying for it wouldn't
actually exist it would never actually
come about in that way so treviris was
founded on the mission of actually
building up and breaking up and creating
a little more transparency into that
black box of what happens with pharmacy
benefits so there's a few core products
in way that we do that one is creating a
apples-to-apples reverse auction bidding
system where your large self-insured
employer so Yael is a likely a
self-insured entity that insures their
pharmacy benefits and they go through a
bidding process to select a PBM or at
least they should every three years a
lot of times that's an opaque process we
have built a technology system that
basically opens that up and says this
PBM versus this PV inverse of this PBM
this is the cost savings it's gonna
happen here's the formulary disruption
that's going to happen here is the
pharmacy this represents gonna happen
here's the best thing for you based upon
these kind
so that as a company you can make the
right decision that hadn't happened
before it was a sort of a broker driven
sort of non-transparent industry on top
of that in the back end we have systems
that check all the claims it says is
this in line with what's actually going
on with the contract not necessarily
that there's malicious activity but
these are complex contracts with you
know tens of thousands of NDC's of drugs
that they're actually looking at and you
need to make sure that they're aligning
to how things actually should happen so
that has been the core of our business
to try and build transparency into that
PBM employer relationship and help the
employer take more control over what's
happening with their pharmacy benefits
that takes us to the other side of the
business where we work with pharmacy
pharmaceutical companies and if you know
anything about sort of the drug supply
chain the kind of the employers on one
side that said in a lot of ways opposed
to the pharmaceutical manufacturers at
two different ends of the supply chain
what we saw and why we got into the life
sciences or the pharmaceutical
manufacturer business was the fact that
after the passing of the ACA co-pays
were increasing deductibles on pharmacy
insurance were increasing coinsurance
was having a much more massive impact on
what people were paying at the pharmacy
they had less of a sense of what exactly
they were gonna pay what they should pay
whether there's assistance that they can
be provided so our business there
focuses on providing solutions that
pharma manufacturers can deploy to the
market to help increase transparency to
patients help increase affordability and
fundamentally access where the
traditional insurance markets might not
be allowing them to get it right there's
statistics that say thirty to forty
percent of people can't afford a four
hundred to a thousand dollar expense at
one point in time and yet a vast
majority of the new products that are
coming to market are thousands or tens
of thousands dollars a month right
there's a massive disconnect there and
yet there are solutions being put into
the market to help make it more
affordable for patients to actually for
those medications so two sides of the
business you'd say those are kind of
very different with very different
audiences
mark talked about the fact that there is
a complex web of peyer's data supply
chain product that goes through this
pharmacy supply chain marketplace our
vision and concept is sort of there has
to be some value chain disruption there
and the more you're able to bring the
two ends of a marketplace closer
together a supply chain closer together
the sort of more efficient you will able
to actually sort of build and create
that marketplace so that's the
background for us great numerous the
earlier speakers had had highlighted the
importance of data data data over and
over again and I I think the story is
probably equally true here that data is
very very important to your businesses
and plays into the kind of digital
solutions that you end up providing can
you talk a bit about the data aspect of
your businesses and how vital it is to
the the funky success of the business
sure so the data side for Val sure kind
of the traditional digital data is
pretty straight forward and we were
ecommerce system nothing all that that
magical about that where data is
particularly important for us is actual
chemical data so we analyzed chemical
properties of medications but of course
that all turns into digital data after
our core technology is based on a
spectroscopy based approach so it's
laser based you end up getting this kind
of bumpy line that that gives you a lot
of the information of the individual
bonds of the the molecules that you're
looking at so you sense we shine a laser
at something and it comes back with this
signature of of what's going on the
medication we use that both for the
active ingredient and also for inactive
ingredients that are in the meds and
we're amassing quite a large proprietary
database in that sense and we do talk a
fair amount about okay what do you do
with that at some point could that be
valuable to the pharma supply chain
could that be valuable to distributors
to hospitals or group purchasing
organizations that are looking to find
the best deals
what about quality being another portion
of that matrix of making purchasing
decisions and we do get a tremendous
amount of information that data I mean
we're able to see when a manufacturer
might have the exact same product but
they've changed factories in a lot of
these manufacturers have factories all
over the world in India and Croatia and
and we've already seen instances where
the product is the same and even the
materials were pretty much the same but
all of a sudden you see the spectra is
changing because they've sourced them
from different places they've had
different amounts and the the impact of
that I think is going to be most
powerful if we eventually at some point
moved to a healthcare system where we're
tracking not just that the medication
was authentic I mean it could be
authentically made badly but but
actually connecting lot numbers to the
medications that people get and so we
have adverse events when we have issues
with chemical data or with any part of
that data and then connecting it direct
to the patient could be a really big
improvement in outcomes in general and
it would be a very data-driven approach
we're actually working with with some
folks to do a resolution to the
government through lobbying groups that
would push for not just serialization of
meds which is already part of the drug
supply Protection Act but connecting
that direct to the patient which also by
the way for healthcare systems could be
very powerful because when you have all
these giant recalls like we've all seen
with the blood pressure medications
valsartan losartan and in those the
pharmacy has no idea what patient got
what lot and some lots are bad some lots
are good and the FDA has had had so much
trouble with this particular recall
they've even shown and published certain
lots that are actually okay but you have
no idea what you got so it doesn't
really help you very much so I think
that's at least an opportunity for data
to make a big play in the pharma space
great John yeah so I mean
data claims data specifically underlies
the core aspects of our entire business
we always like to say that in a lot of
ways sort of getting more data that's
not the problem it's using the data in
the right way and understanding how to
sort of get it into the right hands in
the right methodology so for employers
you think about a thousand mm life
employer plan they might have one person
who's managing all the benefits for that
organization pharmacy benefits regular
health care benefits life insurance
workers compensation everything else
right at the end of the day the pharmacy
benefit probably is a small portion of
what they can do so digging in and
understanding exactly what's happening
is a difficult task so being able to
help that benefit manager or whoever's
understanding their pharmacy benefits
what's going on in their population
whether they are getting the right
products dispensed whether they arguing
the right generics in place of brands
when they should be whether there are
challenges with cost going on this sort
of our core aspect of how we can
leverage that data cleaning it getting
in the right format when you have legacy
sort of claim systems that are sending
things that frankly to me look like
gobbledygook but our engineers and data
scientists are able to sort of transform
into usable pieces of information is
very important the other things that we
think about is data being core in our
business around engagement so in the
pharmaceutical and life sciences space
there's been a lot of focus on trying to
get closer to the patient and help them
understand their medication their
adherence challenges and otherwise and
making sure that we're looking at each
engagement point that a patient has with
their medication or with something else
that goes on with their healthcare
allows you to understand and target
messaging and targets or the adherence
messages to them more effectively rather
than saying you're likely on this
medication it might be time for you to
refill getting a message out there that
says you are on this medication you
filled it 25 days ago you're on a 35
days script you need to fill it now or
else you're gonna miss the your window
actually get that prescription and not
miss a day of therapy and then the last
point is utilizing the data that exists
out there and creating the connections
to create more transparency so if you've
ever tried to go through the
of understanding what your benefits are
for your insurance or for your pharmacy
health benefits you might call the
insurance company there might be some
sort of call center for the insurance
company or pharma company that they
operate and you know you'll call and
okay let me I'm gonna go through this
I'll get back to you
what's happening in the backend is
they're banging on the phones calling it
the insurance companies trying to figure
out exactly what the benefits are or
there's someone going through there all
of that data exists in the backend and
being able to connect that more
transparently with a digital touch so
that a patient can get that information
right up front understand what your
copay is while you're at the doctor's
office or before you go to the pharmacy
so that you're not actually shocked by
showing up to the pharmacy and having a
twelve hundred dollar copay on a product
or that you're gonna have a prior
authorization that your doctor then has
to go back process through and you have
to wait three extra days to get that
medication bringing that up earlier in
the process and pushing that information
down closer to the patient we think will
drive a lot more efficiency and value
into the market great John and thanks
David so one of the things I alluded to
up front was that Amazon is a new
entrant into the space both on one that
one hand I just actually read this
morning that with their pill pack
business they're now starting to
aggressively market this three-year
Amazon Prime account so expect to start
getting some emails asking you if you've
taken your drugs lately and if you want
to buy them through Amazon additionally
on the other side of the the coin Amazon
has teamed up with Berkshire Hathaway
and with JP Morgan to start Haven health
which Atul Gawande is running which is
apparently doing a lot of things to try
to transform and revolutionize things
across the health care spectrum I think
there's obviously a lot that we don't
know about what Amazon is doing but
would love to get both of your
perspectives as to what you think Amazon
is going to be doing in the drug supply
chain in the coming years and how you
think that kind of digital revolution
may or may not transform the industry
and John when we start with you first
yeah so I think the
the point you talked about having Amazon
send emails to you trying to get into
you're a bigger piece of your wallet by
capturing your prescription benefits
instead of your pharmaceutical sort of
claims is the sort of the near-term
component that I think makes the most
sense and where you're gonna see them go
I actually think the time frame you
reference sort of years is probably
gonna be years and years and years you
think about how long it took Amazon to
transform the way we purchase books
groceries and otherwise it's decades to
get there
Healthcare is not as fast-moving a sort
of industry when I started my mentors
always said think about health care
think about what the rest of the world
is doing right now and health care will
be doing in somewhere between 10 and 20
years so I would hope that there will be
some sort of speeding up of that per the
prior conversations of the day but it's
not like this is going to be an
overnight switch I think what Amazon you
know we don't know what they're gonna do
we don't know what Haven health is gonna
do right now it kind of just looks like
a little bit of a consortium of large
buyers coming together to purchase
health care and a more I guess cheaper
or better rate it's probably going to be
more than that we don't know exactly
what it will be but I do think that
Amazon's approach has been sort of
taking everything closer to the customer
making it a better customer experience
health care needs that creating some
marketplaces for all of the different
healthcare services initiatives that we
have is one place that you can imagine
them playing but in the pharmacies or
the supply chain space that's a that's a
place where they can sort of create some
purchasing power and leverage like they
have sort of across the rest of the
markets they operate it that's I am NOT
a wizard of thinking through the future
so don't come to me for that David
so Disney is actually your former boss
at capital rx that mentioned about
Pharmacy Benefit in general oh and I
guess it could be used for a healthcare
system in general the the concept that
there's an industry that's really done a
lot for consolidation as opposed to
innovation and I think that's gonna be
Amazon's big
challenge I think Amazon originally
backed down from from Pharma seen from
health care when they were really kind
of fighting CVS back and forth in 2017
so there's a lot of activity in 2017
about Amazon kind of rumbling that
they're gonna get into healthcare they
were hiring doctors they got some drug
licenses CVS started spending a ton of
money on online advertising they they
started doing two-hour delivery in
Manhattan to kind of you know show
Amazon I think that they could do it
Amazon was doing some - our delivery
Manhattan concepts back then and there
was if you really paid attention the
news which which we paid attention quite
closely on this topic they were gonna
make an announcement at the end of
November in 2017 and everybody's like oh
great Amazon's gonna announce they're
gonna get into pharmacy this is an area
that needs to the needs disruption and
Amazon being the behemoth that it is
could actually stand up to this industry
that has so many layers so many
complexities and then they didn't make
an announcement in December second CBS
announced their sixty nine billion
dollar acquisition of Edna so hard to
ignore that kind of timing and the fact
that they didn't make an announcement
and then a couple months later it was
the Berkshire Hathaway JP Morgan
conglomerate where they gave no details
they basically just said we're gonna
change healthcare with a bunch of really
big names it's nice that it's actually
coming to fruition now perhaps let's see
what they actually do I think there's
still lots of questions about any of the
details what they're really gonna do
with that or not but I think it was
Amazon's to kind of shut off the bout
back to CVS of you know okay you won
this round but we want to be in this we
want to make a difference in healthcare
and I think though however to your point
I mean this is an incredibly complicated
system that doesn't change overnight I
think some of the biggest issues Amazon
is going to have is things like PBMs you
know Caremark Express risk with stress
Crips has dropped pill pack before
and I'm sure they'll do it again as soon
as they decide that it's a threat then
you lose 90 million lives or so insured
lives so the power these companies have
over access to insurance access for
patients is huge and I think Amazon's
challenge is the fact that they want to
make everything easy but this isn't an
easy system and they have to contend
with you know companies like Express
Scripts like CVS that owns not just the
largest pharmacy benefit manager but
also owns the largest chain of
pharmacies and now a huge insurer so the
the the power to block out Amazon is
massive and I think that's that's what's
gonna take years to figure out so as an
online pharmacy how do you think the
sort of Amazon's use of pill pack as
also an online pharmacy but then having
effectively built out it acquired the
number of brick-and-mortar locations to
potentially create that both online and
brick-and-mortar place that we know sort
of in the pharmacy world isn't
accessable when there's medications you
need today and other medications you can
wait for right so from our perspective
versus Amazon perspectives it was very
different
you know Amazon needs to capture a
significant portion of that 500
billion-dollar pharmacy market in order
to move their needle we're not so big so
we're able you know to carve out niches
where it matters most for people and I
think if you look at any of the other
online pharmacies or most of them
they're very niche focus you know hymns
in Rome and they get a lot of play now
is just erectile dysfunction medications
and sexual health medications you know I
have companies like pill club that I
think raise just sixty million dollars
recently and it's birth control that
come with chocolates so you know niches
and we hope that we're starting off with
niches like mental health medications
you know heart health medications
neurology working with potentially some
big clients or even clients like
Catholics that are not a huge PBM but
for us is great to start off there
and then grow with a universal value add
that could potentially affect the
industry as a whole as opposed to just
big niches but yeah big versus small has
a lot of impact on your business model
in most markets as sixty million dollar
raise wouldn't wouldn't indicate a niche
market right right health care is so
massive yeah well on that topic of sixty
million dollar raises Gregg had raised a
point up front that the invest in
dollars in digital health have been
ballooning exponentially and this is a
little bit of a case in point for that
where do you think it goes from here do
you think this ride continues up
indefinitely or or does some kind of
reality hit the market that some of
these things are playing out and some of
these things are and and and valuations
come down and dollars come down so if
you really look at those numbers closely
for the last three four years you know
venture capital dollars have kind of
leveled off a little bit as a whole
slight increase but what's been a huge
change and I think across the markets is
the checks sizes get bigger and bigger
and the total checks go down so I think
the the general VC mark and I don't know
as much on the granular side of digital
health but definitely as a whole has
become more and more risk-averse I think
kind of the heyday of like I got an idea
oh here's the check and some money which
never really existed but more or less
maybe in Silicon Valley
but I think that's kind of gone away
largely and I think that the venture
capitalists are taking more conservative
bets with bigger checks and more
established could be a niche right so I
think I think healthcare does lend
itself a lot to niches they're still
massive but yeah they're definitely
being more conservative my perspective
is basically the VCS are in this for
just giving away money for the sake of
giving away money and they need to sort
of get some returns on it eventually and
with a lot of digital health investments
that they have made over the past call
it five to nine years they haven't seen
sort of the exit velocity either
throughout
positions or IPOs that you technically
may have seen from some other sort of
heavily back to VC markets so you know
pillpack right there's all this digital
health investment and that's a huge exit
for you know the healthcare market it's
a billion dollars right that's a big
exit but the amount of money that's been
put into the market there haven't been
sort of the call it the lifts the ubers
the other companies that are worth tens
of billions of dollars that you see
across these other heavily invested sort
of venture backed industries and
actually it's one more point on that
which was just in the New York Times
like a couple weeks ago there's a big
article talking about a variety of these
online pharmacies like Rome and like
hims and and and others that have kind
of gotten into a gray regulatory area
and so I think also with healthcare you
know it's one thing to have all these
startups going in every direction but
you can start to innovate faster than
the law catches up and regulator's
catching up you know we know from our
context of the DEA they're very
concerned about the particular class of
online pharmacy where there's a doctor
involved right and so a lot of these
sexual health pharmacies are the whole
point is that wow this is embarrassing
don't go and talk to your doctor come to
us and fill out a form and we'll
essentially just give you some meds and
there's supposedly some doctor somewhere
that's writing and signing off on all
this and the doctors are starting to get
pissed off about this like there's a
reason you're this requires a
prescription you're supposed to talk to
your doctor about it it can be bad for
you if you don't and this New York Times
article it was talking about a lot of
these lapses where like they're not even
telling you what the doctor was and all
these things that even changed as soon
as the New York Times got interested in
it and started asking questions so I
think that's another perhaps headwind
for these venture capitalists and such
is that yeah they're they were pouring
money into this and they're like all
crap knew this all be shut down so
definitely a consideration in health as
opposed to kind of standard tech
companies great thanks guys
let me turn it over to the audience for
some Q&A
well of course I had to get up here and
be first in line to ask a question
there's so many interesting things that
you've brought up and so many
interesting topics but but let me let me
let me dive into this one so it in in
some ways this is a David and Goliath
story you know Traverse Valley Shore
disruptive companies using disruptive
technology taking on the large
incumbents the evil corporations we're
not going to be happy about this
so III guess my question is really what
reaction have you seen and what reaction
do you expect in for them not to let
this happen whether its efficiency in
pricing whether its efficiency and
information around around drug supply in
purity have you seen anything what do
you anticipate and and how can you kind
of protect yourself really for for
things that ultimately bring benefit to
to patients and consumers I'll start
with that one I guess so while employers
on these sort of the payer side of a
business are our core clients the PBMs
are actually key partners to us right
the marketplace doesn't exist unless it
is essentially two sides to it so you
know yes there's a little pushback
against it and there's the goal to sort
of own as much data and as much of the
information as possible but sort of
there's an S necessity of actually
taking part in something when you know
your client as the employer sort of
wants to go Thunder process and actually
take that in the case so sure there's
pushback but I think in general everyone
sees it as a is a necessary sort of step
towards the future on the life sciences
side how it mixes with our payer side of
the business right a lot of times you
hear about copay programs and
affordability programs being at odds
with EMS and otherwise if you follow
anything in the news there are these
things called copay accumulators whereby
PBMs
are starting to not count any sort of
copay support that you get from a
manufacturer or someone else towards
your deductible or out of
at maximum there are certain laws and
state legislatures that are being passed
to make that illegal or to supplant that
with something else so there's a lot of
I guess uh you know trading going on of
blows to figure out exactly what's going
to happen and sort of our perspective is
that there got there has to be a way to
bring those a little bit closer together
the two parties closer together so that
sort of at odds with one another when
both in a lot of ways they're trying to
get do the same thing which is to get a
product of value that's going to help so
much health care into the patient's
hands let me actually throw the investor
perspective in on this as well so
[Music]
innovations that are somewhat easy to
replicate be it you know same-day
delivery or be it even a very basic
online portal CVS has proven that they
can very quickly follow where digital
pharmacies or smaller digital innovators
go so the competitive advantage just
gets melts away to to quickly really for
an investor to get excited the areas
where investors have really gotten
excited or areas that either fill niches
that the big established players can't
really quite get at like good rx which
is solving a niche for cash pay
consumers that they and generic drugs
where they can't otherwise solve it or
businesses actually like Valley Shore
where IP is an important element so so I
think that that sort of niche with a
barrier to end or the high barrier to
entry is sort of at least the investor
side of where where people are focusing
yeah I guess I'll just say that the
complexity of the healthcare system
definitely allows for multiple different
kinds of reactions you know I guess you
could imagine that the manufacturers are
not terribly happy about of ala sure you
know they never had somebody
independently looking over the shoulder
nobody likes people looking over their
shoulder but in that sense you know
we've we've gone through a lot of legal
work and in consultation and we've
always come down to the fact that
science is the best defense that the
truth is the best defense and we
actually we published our first
scientific study a few months ago and we
were looking at and you know one of the
biggest over-the-counter medications
acetaminophen in brand-name Tylenol
and when the biggest product lines is
rapid release and so we actually did an
over a thousand product study that
showed that actually the ones labeled
rapid release are slower to release than
the standard versions that are cheaper
they actually put these kind of blue and
red coatings that look really nice but
slow them down so you know everybody
thought oh you're gonna get sued do you
know all these things are gonna happen
and we published in a peer reviewed
syndicate Journal the Washington Post
covered it and did a whole feature on it
and I'm sure they weren't happy about it
to that point they did officially
comment and and so on but no lawsuits
came in in the other way and I think it
was one of the things that other people
in industry started saying like well
we're we're a hospital and we have a
bunch of medication we care about the
the quality of care for our patients and
they reacted very positively that great
that you're doing these kinds of work we
want to work with you to do other
studies on other medications and perhaps
bring medications into our systems so
you can get a variety of reactions but I
think the consumer angle of all of this
has become so much more important that
ultimately the industry is beholden to
the consumer the fact that good or X
exists is simply because there's this
whole loop around where you have this
cash pay capability that goes around
this entire system and again it's big
enough that that it turns into
billion-dollar businesses not big enough
for Amazon to play purely in that but
for a lot of other companies it is so
yeah a lot of angles on the product
quality thing no I think from the
manufacturer standpoint they've spent a
lot of money on sort of in market post
market tracking of product quality and
sort of making sure that if anything
comes up that they're following up on it
and sort of tracking those batches so if
someone is sort of getting it from the
point where it never gets to the point
of actually having to be in market with
probably quality hypothetically I would
imagine that there could be a benefit
across the board there yeah I think
ultimately there's a lot of benefit
specifically of what what voucher does
and it being very different than
anything that's been done in the
industry before in this area I'm sure
it'll ruffle some feathers but I agree
that it's a overall value add like how
can you are
with higher quality medications so we'll
just do one more question I'm over
standing between everybody and lunch
that's not a good place to be except
I'll keep this short but you mentioned I
think John in particular trying to bring
you know n payers employers and some of
the manufacturers closer together do you
see any solutions or is part of your
role going to the policymakers to try
and make that make it more capable for
for manufacturers to provide you know
products directly to those that are
actually paying for it versus having all
the the middlemen yeah so I think you're
seeing a lot of news around what's
happening in through the legislators in
Congress around sort of that and the
potential elimination of safe harbors on
rebates
maybe the implicate the actual addition
of safe harbors on copay support within
the Medicare space going to purely net
pricing dynamics from a manufacturer to
PBM I think the product flow is probably
always going to sort of stay somewhat
the same in the sense that the
wholesaling market in otherwise exists
in the same way if there's a lot of
other industries
it's the payment flow that might change
a whole lot I think that the biggest
challenge is there's a lot of contracts
that exist around the gross price net
price dynamic that exists and there's
got to be some significant transition
periods to move out of that you are
seeing manufacturers drop certain and
have certain
NDC's come out with net price dynamics
you have optimum and another number of
other so the PBM starting to talk about
purely pass-through formularies and
passing through the rebate savings for
you know your patients in deductibles we
haven't seen a lot of that actually come
through in the actual implementation
it'll be interesting to see what happens
there but it's an unsustainable market
where you have increasingly a small
percentage of patients basically exposed
to a very high increasing gross price
but the market in the industry overall
sort of creating less and less growth
every single year on a net basis so I
don't know exactly what the solutions
are going to be but I do think sort of
maybe marketplaces other things where
you can carve out different pieces of
what the employers are buying and what
the pharmaceutical manufacturers are I
guess putting it in place going through
some direct rebates directly to
employers to make sure that they're able
to manage their own formularies better
there's a lot of different solutions
that are being explored I would say that
immediate change is not something you're
gonna see but it's gonna be an evolution
great John David really appreciate your
time and and thanks again to everyone
thank you very much thank you guys
[Applause]